this is indeed a special events
broadcast of a genuine special event a
total eclipse of the Sun visible today
over North America last total eclipse of
the Sun for North America for the year
2017 on August 21st there will be a
total solar eclipse across the United
States for the first time in 38 years
the total solar eclipse of 2017 is gonna
be epic I've never seen a total solar
eclipse but I'm doing everything I can
to travel to see this with my own eyes
and this is why you know why we have
eclipses oh sure well you don't have to
say another word this is the earth and
the moon the scale if the earth were
this big the moon would be this big and
this far apart the Sun is 400 times the
size of the moon but it's also 400 times
further away
that trick of perspective is why they
look the same size in the sky and why
during a total eclipse the moon covers
the Sun perfectly just the right size
and the right distance away too very
neatly block out the Sun if the moon
orbited on the same plane as the earthly
Sun eclipses would happen once a month
but the moon orbits on a tilt a little
more than five degrees because of this
tilt it lines up with the Sun very very
it's only when the three bodies are in a
straight line that in a clip can occur
but the reason to see in Eclipse isn't
because it's rare it's because of how it
will make you feel right now belt it's
daytime out here but in a few seconds
it's going to go from daytime to
nighttime there are thousands of people
here who were just a few minutes away
from totality it's a strange eerie light
out here and the horizon is beginning to
darken right now look at that it's
amazing how the temperature is dropped
to the past few minutes oh look at this
look at this look at the shadows
sweeping over
[Applause]
look at that man during a total solar
eclipse you can sense this distance in
the sky this kind of event puts you in
touch with the cosmos you can feel the
motions of the heavenly bodies you can
feel how vast our solar system is it has
to be one of the coolest things I've
ever seen
I am so excited I've never had a preview
of an eclipse before like that
[Music]